Sevilla or Seville is the largest city
in the beautiful region of Andalusia
it's a city with a long history of
different Empires religions and cultures
it has stood as the center point for
politics in the region since the
al-mahads made it the capital of the
andalusi part of their empire in the
12th century and long being associated
with flourishing literature scholarship
arts and religion and a lot of this can
be experienced and felt even as you
visit the city today a bustling Place
full of life in the hearts of southern
Spain
as a visitor you can experience
beautiful places like the plaza de
Espana or hang out at one of the
thousands of Tapas bars in the city but
in terms of religion and religious
history the obvious Main Attraction are
its many stunning Catholic churches
there are plenty of them each with their
own distinct flavor and history but the
centerpiece of it all is of course the
Civil Cathedral or the Cathedral of
Saint Mary of the sea it's an absolutely
massive structure incredibly detailed
and ornate in its architecture indeed
this is one of the largest cathedrals in
the world in history often counted as
the third or fourth largest in the world
and definitely the largest Gothic
Cathedral or really the largest Gothic
religious building on the planet
considered a UNESCO world heritage site
this is a truly remarkable building both
on the inside and out the cathedral was
built from the 15th to the early 16th
century and on the site of the old Grand
Mosque of the city
before Sevilla was conquered by the
Christian forces of Ferdinand III in
1247 the city had been ruled by Muslim
dynasties for many centuries
since the umayyad forces entered the
Iberian Peninsula in 7-Eleven this
region which is not in Arabic as
al-andalus was a major Hub and center of
the Islamic world and for the world
generally
different dynasties and Empires took
turn ruling this region the Umayyads the
thought if Estates the almoravids and
the al-mahads and it was especially
under the al-muhads who ruled from
around 1147 to the mid 13th century that
Seville which was called ishpilia in
Arabic came to play a central role as
the capital of Andalucia the city became
a center for culture scholarship and
indeed mysticism or Sufism
there was a great flourishing of
mysticism in Seville during the 12th to
13th Centuries with many significant
figures living there together
it was here that one of the greatest
Sufi thinkers in history IBN Arabi
basically grew up spent most of his life
as a young adult and entered on the
spiritual path under civilian Masters
other significant Mystics such as Abu
madyyan and ibnbarajan were also
connected with the city
because it became such an important city
in different ways it of course required
a big Grand Mosque where communal Friday
prayers could be held and house as many
worshipers as possible for this reason
the Grand Mosque of Seville was
constructed beginning in the 1170s and
being finished in early 1198.
this was an incredibly impressive mask
at the time especially the minaret which
was one of the largest in the world
the building served as the Grand Mosque
of the city until the Christian conquest
in 1247 after which it was turned into a
cathedral
at first the situation was similar to
what we find in the mosque Cathedral of
Cordoba where the same building was used
only modified the orientation of the
interior was changed to fit the
Christian model and several chapels were
added among other changes sadly this
original building having both served as
a mosque and then as a cathedral no
longer survives today with the exception
of a few details in 1356 an earthquake
destroyed parts of the building and a
few decades later in 1401 they decided
to basically rebuild the whole thing
gradually removing all sections of the
old building to construct a new one
after almost a century in 1506 the new
cathedral was completed which is the
structure that we find today
and it is a truly awe-inspiring building
just standing outside while waiting to
enter you can look at the intricately
detailed motifs and Architectural
details on the walls and the doors and
the towers once on the inside you are
struck by the sheer size of the place
the fact that it is the largest Gothic
cathedral in the world makes a lot of
sense when you're standing on the inside
it's absolutely enormous the Nave is
very long the place has 80 chapels all
with beautiful pieces of art ritual
objects and Relics of different sorts
there are various depictions of Jesus
Mary and other figures including the
famous early Christian Martyrs Justa and
rufina who are very important for the
city of Seville and its Christian
Heritage
[Music]
the cathedral even has some of the
remains of Christopher Columbus and I'm
Monument to house them
Columbus lived in Seville for a while
and his body rested there for a while
too before eventually being moved to
what is today the Dominican Republic but
it is claimed that there are a few
pieces of him that remain here in the
cathedral
two of the church's most famous aspects
are its beautiful and large choir
section and it's absolutely amazing
Altarpiece this piece by Pierre duncant
finished in 1564 is massive and its
beauty simply takes your breath away
covered in Gold this wooden structure is
20 meters high and consists of smaller
compartments depicting scenes from the
gospels and on the bottom row a
beautiful depiction of Mary with baby
Jesus in the form known as the virgin of
the sea consider the patron saint of the
city of Seville and which of course the
whole Cathedral is named after it really
is a place where you can spend a full
day just looking at all the beautiful
details and features and experience
history in an aesthetic way to be in a
place that has served a sacred purpose
for people for centuries both Christians
and of course earlier Muslims in fact
even though most of it was demolished
there were a few features of the old
mosque Cathedral that still survive
parts of a wall at the back of the
church and of course the courtyard known
as the courtyard of orange trees
including one of the original gates from
the al-mahad period And I think the
original fountain
this is the courtyard where Muslims
would enter to make abolutions washing
themselves before going into the
building itself to pray
[Music]
and of course the main aspect that has
survived and one of the most famous
parts of the whole Cathedral is of
course the bell tower known as the
hiralda this Tower used to be the old
minaret for the mosque and has gone
largely unchanged over the many
centuries
it Still Remains a really imposing
structure towering over the streets when
the Christians converted the mosque into
a cathedral and even with later
reconstructions they kept the minaret
intact but modified only the top part
adding a bell tower
so as you look at the tower you can see
different eras of history right in front
of you most of it the bottom two-thirds
basically are from the old man rat
largely unchanged whereas the top has
this added structure of of large bells
and of course the the figure at the top
which is known as it's called the
hiralda which is what the tower is named
after it's a really fascinating and
beautiful thing to look at
foreign
[Music]
there's a great image that shows the
tower in its different phases the left
part being the minaret the right part
being the bell tower before
reconstructions and the middle one being
the structure as it stands now
if you want to experience the old
Islamic history of the site in
particular this is the place to do it in
the courtyard by the fountain where the
old Al mahad wall and gate in front of
you and the Towering hiralda looking
down from above
using old religious sites to build new
ones is a very common practice the same
was done by the Muslims with the Aya
Sofia and Constantinople or what is
today Istanbul and by Christians in
various other places even in Seville
another one of the most famous churches
the Church of El Salvador was built on
the site of an even older mosque it was
here that the IBN adabas mosque stood
built during the umayyad times in the
9th century and serving as the city's
main mosque until the construction of
the Grand Mosque in the 12th century
it's a place that's mentioned by people
like IBN Arabi in his writings and has a
long history and reputation in the
region today much like the great
Cathedral only parts of the old
Courtyard and minaret survive where the
old entrance used to be
this is actually one of the Hidden gems
of the city in my opinion you enter the
courtyard from a small entrance in the
middle of a busy street and it's really
easy to miss but once you're inside
you're met with a really tranquil and
peaceful place with a fountain in the
middle and a chapel on the walls you can
still see remnants from the umayyad
building with the pillars and arches
surviving also showcasing that the
ground level used to be further down
back then because you can only see that
the top of the pillars basically
coming here in the evenings when it is
dark is especially beautiful it was a
great experience to essentially be there
alone and drink in the history and
memory of all the people that have been
there but even today this is the place
of one of the most beautiful churches in
the city the Church of San Salvador was
finished in 1712 and is a really
beautiful Baroque building that is
easily accessible in one of the main
squares in central Seville and it's open
to visitors
both this and the Civil Cathedral are
some of the most impressive churches
I've ever visited the Church of San
Salvador is filled with chapels each one
more elaborate and artistically stunning
than the next depictions of Jesus and
different scenes from the gospels Saints
and other important figures
it also has a breathtaking depiction of
the Virgin Mary in the particular form
known as the virgin of el rocho that is
especially popular in the region around
Seville this is a really unique and
elaborate Motif with the Virgin and
child in stunning clothing that
completely took my breath away
but arguably the most important aspect
of the church is much like the Civil
Cathedral the absolutely incredible
Altarpiece from the 18th century this
thing is absolutely huge and imposing
depicting a kind of ascending Journey
from the Earth all the way up to the
heavens through Jesus and to God the
father on top this is the kind of art
piece that you can just stand there and
stare at for hours and still find
amazing details buildings like this and
its art are often constructed precisely
to be imposing to give a sense of the
greatness of the Divine and its power
and when you stand in a place like this
or in the Civil Cathedral that feeling
really comes through as you are often
filled with awe over the very scale of
it all
[Music]
on a personal level there are of course
certain things that are going to stand
up more than others when you're on a
trip like this as many of you know I
primarily specialize in Islam and Sufism
which is why that aspect of the city's
history is especially relevant for me
many of the andalucian mystics such as
IBN Arabi have been close companions for
many years and it was really special to
spend some time in the place where he
basically grew up and started his
mystical Journey
of course Seville has changed a whole
lot since the 12th century so it can be
hard to imagine what things would have
been like and to connect to that history
in a more direct sense sure you can go
to the Courtyard of the Civil Cathedral
or the old ibnadaba's mosque and
experience some of that but at the same
time most of the things around you are
modern structures but what was
especially powerful in this regard was
instead to take a trip to the hills
outside the city in the midst of nature
even Arabi often talks about these Hills
outside Seville in his biographical
writings and he had several important
experiences here and unlike the city
environment these places have changed
relatively little over the centuries the
same Hills would have been there the
landscape would have been essentially
the same the same plans can be felt and
smelled this experience brought me
especially close to some of those
figures that I have spent so much time
getting to know intellectually over the
years it was almost like getting to know
them a bit more personally which was
really interesting and fascinating the
hills to the west of Seville are filled
with called Roman ruins known as italica
which are really interesting to visit in
themselves but it's also true that
Mystics used to go on spiritual retreats
in solitude and old ruins would have
been perfect places to do so
this kept going through my mind as I was
walking through the tunnels in Old
buildings maybe some of those great
Mystics sat in these very places in deep
meditation
but in general sitting there and looking
out over the natural landscape that
would have remained largely unchanged
over the centuries was really special
another famous Mystic ibnbarajan moved
to the countryside outside Seville
specifically to be closer to this nature
and to come closer to the Divine through
contemplation and meditation on nature
as a sacred scripture and to be in that
environment that he would have
contemplated was really special
whatever your particular interests
happen to be Seville is a really
beautiful place filled with so much
history and beautiful places to visit
you can connect both with its long
Muslim history but also with the equally
significant Christian Heritage and its
incredibly beautiful cathedrals and
churches that are still active today it
is one of the central places in the
region of Andalusia and has been at
least in some periods its spiritual
heart
I'll see you next time
[Music]
foreign